first on cbs this morning you have no
idea how much i like saying that so i'ma
say it again
first on cbs this morning we're
revealing the largest single
individual gift ever to support
scholarships at historically black
colleges and university
netflix co-founder and ceo that's reid
hastings and his wife patty quillin say
they will give 120 million dollars
to be split equally among morehouse
spelman
colleges in the united negro college
fund that's 120
million dollars of their own money we
spoke with hastings as well as morehouse
college president that's david a thomas
spellman college president that's mary
schmidt campbell and michael
l lomax he's president and ceo of the
united negro college fund
hastings told us why he decided to make
this historic contribution
with his wife patty about
five years ago i set up a program at my
alma mater
and so i was telling michael lomax you
know
look at what i'm doing at bowdoin
college and he said well that's great
but um you know there's this whole other
world
and what happens is that white capital
tends to flow to predominantly white
institutions
and it's just what you know and are
comfortable with and have grown up with
and he offered to help paddy and i get
to know the hbcus
and then this year with a tragedy in
america
and everyone feeling hopeless we
realized
this is the time to do something bigger
and to really try to bring the
hbcu story front and center
dr lomax it sounds like we have you to
thank on some level about this
when you heard that reed and and his
wife were doing this what was your
initial reaction
well rita and i have known one another
for 15 years i knew they needed to go to
a range of colleges and i always felt
that historically black colleges were
going to be centrally important for that
so you know i i was making the case to
to patty and read great education
at historically black colleges but we
need great philanthropists to step up
and invest dr campbell how did you hear
the news
and what was your reaction patty uh
explained that what they wanted to do
was to to provide a gift of 20 million
dollars
to fund 10 students a year over the next
10 year with
full tuition room and board scholarships
the very next day
the very next day patty sent
an email around again to michael david
and me
and this time said you know we've been
thinking
and we've decided to make it 40 million
dollars and i just
about fainted at that point
is such an affirmation of all of those
gifted hard-working students who want to
come to places like spelman
and morehouse now we have the resources
to
support 200 students each of us
over the next 10 years that that's a
game changer dr thomas what will this
money mean to morehouse
i think it will also transform how
people look at hbcus
you also have to put this in the context
of what's been happening here in it
right
right during the first week of protest
a student from both spelman and
morehouse where together were tased and
pulled out of the car by police
i had been with my students who are
taking leadership
in the protest and writing to them and
telling them you know you got to
practice what you've been what what
you've been taught here at morehouse
what it represents
and what is that what you've been taught
here
is to create change non-violent social
action
the vote organizing
educating and leaders leading and
serving
i wrote to read later that what i really
felt
in his and patties reaching out was a
true partnership
then the 40 million dollar email came
and
my wife had to tell me to put her down
[Laughter]
i love that i love it did you know you
were going to do 40 or did you do
20 and then say you know what let's kick
it up a notch
we realized that if we really want to
support
the hbcus in the right way we should dig
deeper
and so that's where you know patty and i
wanted to really go big and
really start the ball rolling as big and
wonderful as this gift is
it's a drop in the bucket compared to
the knee the wonderful thing about this
gift is patty and reed
did not want the gift named after them
so spelman college
chose to name it after one of our alums
you said they didn't want the gift
named after them read please please
explain
very few people again extraordinary
would give money of this magnitude and
say you know i don't mind if you name a
wing after me or if you call it after me
um so in both cases we really want the
gift to symbolize
you know great black achievement through
the hbus
people that know you say that you are a
very private person you and patty
absolutely but you know it does help to
bring attention
uh by coming forward and really
explaining why the
hbcus are such a great resource such a
historic
so much resilience and so many chapters
of that story
and what a difference they make in black
education in america
so you guys have all heard that phrase
go big or go home
read and patty you do not have to go
home because you went
really big he went really big but you
know just if i may
this gift uh is the largest
single gift made to uncf
and our hbcus in 76 years of history
uh it is uh made by
private individuals patty and reed need
to be inspirations to more people
to give dr lomax are you all optimistic
about
where we're heading i will be optimistic
when i see other people stepping up
as patti and reid have stepped up and
that they are saying
we stand in solidarity with these
movements you know dr king said the ark
of the moral universe is long but it
bends
toward justice the ark does not
bend on its own we have to put our
shoulders to it to help
it bend we need more people to join in
doing that work
and reed and patty have certainly done
that another thing anthony that's worth
pointing out is that
the couple went two more house in
spelman and and met with some of the
students there spent time with some of
the students there they were blown away
by what they saw they were knocked out
by
the students and the potential and they
said we want to do more and
they also wanted to elevate the profile
of hbcus and they have certainly done
that
it's an extraordinary thing that they've
done and the largest gift ever
to these schools in the unc so bravo
yeah it's a game-changing yeah it's a
game-changing kind of gift gale and what
i really do love about it as you point
out at the end is
they're not asking for their name to be
put on a building or anything like that
and and and that and that to me is is
everything here it's it's all going to
them and
and to glorify what they're doing and
and i love seeing that i really do gail
yeah that's the thing that that struck
me too anthony i don't know anybody that
does that and just says you can call it
you know
my name but this is the thing they said
they would have kept it private but
they're hoping that
they're leading by example that other
people will see what they've done
otherwise we would never hear about it
the only reason they're going public
is because they're hoping others will do
the same and will want to step up
it's so nice